there have been moments in this debate
today that have been amongst the most
harrowing moments that i can remember in
11 years in parliament
and i want to start by paying tribute to
the members for the isle of wight
plymouth moore view
and in particular the members for
tonbridge and malling and barnsley
central
they make me proud to be a member of
this house no matter how painful and
difficult it has been for them over
recent weeks to speak up they have done
it
and they have done the veterans of
afghanistan proud and they have shown
themselves to be true friends to the
afghan people
they have refused to despair even at the
darkest moments because they know better
than most of us that despair is a luxury
that afghans and the world simply cannot
afford
and they've given voice to something
today
that tens of thousands of families in
britain are feeling our friends our
neighbors our constituents who served
who lost loved ones who suffered
life-changing injuries and are wondering
now what this was all for
they should not accept that this is the
end of two decades of sacrifice that the
degradation of terrorists the hard-won
progress for women and girls the
landmine clearance program their access
to healthcare the clean water and the
emergence of fragile democracy can be
allowed to unravel in just a few days
while the world looks away
and like so many of us that
speaking in this debate today they are
finding it impossible to reconcile
that this is where we are now and how it
could possibly have come to this
we recognize that the decision by the
united states to withdraw its military
presence created an impossible
situation for the united kingdom as the
member for maidenhead said nato's
intention was always to withdraw
but it was to withdraw in a planned and
orderly way linked to conditions this
has failed all of those tests
18 months
after the decision was made to withdraw
at doha and four months after the
timetable was established the airport is
overwhelmed paperwork cannot be
processed and ministers now openly admit
that people will be left behind and some
of those will die
this is an unparalleled moment of shame
for this government
security at the airport is now in the
gift of the taliban and it appears that
the government has no agreement beyond
the 31st of august in just 12 days time
is it correct that we are wholly reliant
on a fragile agreement between the
united states and the taliban a deal
that offers no guarantees that uk
evacuations can continue if the us
withdrawal is completed before that date
and our own is not is it correct that no
conversations have taken place between
the uk and taliban leaders about that
access does he realize
as the member for walthamstow said that
his own department is still advising
british nationals remaining in
afghanistan to shelter in place unless
further flight options become available
and to keep an eye on twitter for
updates
the tragedy of all of this
is that even those people who the
government recognizes like the chiefling
scholars who the prime minister made a
personal promise to this week and this
morning have told us that they cannot
get through the taliban roadblocks to
the airport and they will be abandoned
prime minister this has so much
significance for those young afghans
they represent a generation of promising
leaders who are watching the future that
they worked for and hope for unravel in
front of their eyes people especially
women
have burned documents that link them to
the uk for their own safety and so
they're being turned away at airport
perimeters there is a british national
who's been sheltering in a park in kabul
with her young children in recent days
because her house was burnt down and
local people are too scared to offer
them shelter their mp
was promised a phone call from the
foreign secretary's private office two
days ago it hasn't come
what use are promises that are never
ever kept the prime minister made
promises this morning that practically
at this time he knows the government
cannot fulfill the foreign secretary has
to address this today as so many members
have said one of the consequences of the
chaos that ministers have allowed to
engulf us is that people will not trust
us again what can he tell them today
that will start to put that right now he
will have heard the member for normanton
talk about the number of people who
helped us that the government still
refuses to recognize how have we become
this country that drags its feet
on saving the lives of those who
supported us who stand by while the
refugee crisis unfolds the prime
minister said last night we would take
twenty thousand refugees but how can
anyone believe him he has made these
promises before he promised he would
protect the alf dub scheme and give
sanctuary to child refugees and then he
closed it
mr speaker we are better than this
the government has given us a press
release what we need is a plan what is
the scale of the refugee crisis that the
government anticipates what efforts have
they made to coordinate a global
response through the united nations
based on a clear assessment of the needs
of afghans not numbers plucked out of
thin air with no plan to implement them
if i were in his shoes i would be moving
heaven and earth to ensure we live up to
our obligations and show the world we
can be relied on not least for those
women and girls who we encouraged and
supported to take on positions of
authority
and now find themselves the target of
taliban brutality where is the message
from the united kingdom that they are
not alone
when the prime minister took office two
years ago we led the world in
development assistance but even now
after the taliban have taken control
there is no urgency or seriousness about
the humanitarian crisis that confronts
us
can we be honest it is not honest to
claim to be doubling aid to afghanistan
when just a few months ago it was cut in
half
he should remember it mr speaker the
only statement he's ever made to this
house on afghanistan was when he came to
tell us that he was cutting the aid
budget i wonder if he'll reveal after
this debate is over that the refugee
program the government unveiled this
morning will be paid for by raiding the
aid budget i will give way thank
you
you raised at the point of how many
times the prime minister spoke of
afghanistan in the chamber apologies the
shadow foreign secretary mentions that
the amount of times that the prime
minister spoke about afghanistan in this
house can you please remind us how many
times she has ever said the word
afghanistan in this place since she came
to the front bench
and i'm glad she raises this point mr
speaker because it is a sign of a
government that is
it's not my responsibility please let's
try not to use you because i'm not the
example
i'm glad she raises this point mr
speaker because it is a sign of a
government that is increasingly
desperate that they launch these sort of
desperate attacks let me tell her let me
tell her what we have been doing in
recent months in april my colleague the
member for wentworth and dern told the
defense secretary now with the full
withdrawal of nato troops it is hard to
see a future without bloodier conflict
wider taliban control and greater
jeopardy for those afghanis who work
with the west and for women now in
political judicial academic and business
roles last month my honorable friend the
shadow first secretary of state said if
we simply wash our hands and walk away
it is hard they don't want to hear it mr
speaker because they have been warned
and warned and warned about the
consequences by members on all sides of
this house and they have ignored us they
have ignored their own back benches and
they have abandoned the people of
afghanistan it is a moment of shame and
they should apologize
now mr speaker
it is dishonest to claim to be doubling
aid to afghanistan when it was cut in
half and i wonder if what we'll find out
after this debate is over is that the
refugee programme that the government
unveiled this morning will also be paid
for by raiding the aid budget the
foreign secretary has said we can't just
hand over funds to the taliban he is
right but that means we have to work
harder and smarter has he mapped the
capacity across afghanistan to deliver
aid has he spoken to the united nations
who intend to provide a presence on the
ground when did he talk to them what
have they agreed has he spoken to the
international ngos who've been there for
years and why hasn't he yet agreed a
common approach with the american
government who i spoke to last night
forgive me mr speaker no one will be
reassured by the prime minister's
remarks this morning there was no
serious plan to deal with the reality of
taliban rule or the threat to the uk we
went into afghanistan to degrade the
capability of al qaeda after three a bit
of humility from the defense secretary
might be in order
given given
given his
given what is unfolding in front of our
eyes at kabul airport a bit of humility
might be in order
we went into afghanistan after 67
british citizens were murdered in the 9
11 attacks and thanks to the success of
our armed forces there has been no
terrorist attack launched from
afghanistan for 20 years but now we've
been chased from the country by the
taliga taliban giving encouragement to
those who wish us harm
our counter-terror operation appears to
have collapsed what can the foreign
secretary tell us that he is doing to
build up the intelligence picture beyond
kabul and share intelligence with
international partners he has got to
outline today a strategy for dealing
with the new reality we find ourselves
in what leverage does the government
think in practical terms we can exert
over the brutal taliban regime that took
power through violence that displaced a
democratically elected government a
regime that persecutes women journalists
lgbt and religious minorities to name
but a few we should be identifying any
leverage that we have freezing the
assets of the aspan government or
central bank that are in uk accounts or
financial institutions developing
sanctions with our partners and making
clear the consequences of afghanistan
once again becoming a safe haven for
international terrorism mr speaker what
we're witnessing is the absence of
leadership we hold the presidency of the
g7 we're permanent members of the u.n
security council we are leading members
of nato but they are behaving as if they
have no agency and no power missing in
action when it mattered dragged to the
chamber today to account for the
greatest foreign policy crisis of our
generation it should be sobering for the
government that not one single speech
today has been uncritical of their
approach in the cold hard light of the
catastrophe unfolding in afghanistan
their approach to the world looks so
much less palatable than the global
britain gloss that they've tried to coat
it with slashing aid with shameful
slogans like the giant cash machine in
the sky that pulled the rug out from
under people who relied on us promising
to maintain the size of the armed forces
in the election and then cutting them to
the smallest
size for 300 years needlessly repeatedly
trashing the alliances that we need in
the world and our reputation
deliberately violating international law
and shutting down
safe and legal routes to asylum who can
say now that that isn't a shameful
decision given what we are witnessing in
afghanistan the decision to withdraw
troops mr speaker did not need to lead
to this
i've heard the foreign secretary say in
recent days that there was no
alternative but to leave like this but
it is not true we could have used the
last 18 months to plan our exit
to make clear to the afghan people that
we had no intention of walking away from
them or their ongoing aspiration for
democracy to withdraw with care planning
and reduced efforts to be a long-term
partner to the afghan people even
without our troops on the ground the
alternative to chaotic exit is not
endless war as he's tried to argue but
the patient tireless pursuit of peace
and a government that has the stamina to
commit we should be inspired by the
troops the aid workers the journalists
the photographers the support staff the
civilian contractors the armed forces
who returned to evacuate people in
recent days and the diplomatic staff and
most of all the ambassador who has
embodied what courage looked like who
have stayed and remained to help those
who are trying to exit they stand for
something important they stand for a
country that feels a deep sense of
responsibility to our fellow human
beings and believe that when we make
promises we should keep them
they stand for a country that knows that
the world beyond our shores shapes the
lives of people in villages towns and
cities across this country and we cannot
ever afford to turn away and they are
supported as it turns out by very many
more people than we ever knew in every
nation and region people believe that we
can be a force for good in the world and
through this awful crisis they have
found their voice women's groups raising
the alarm for their brave afghan
counterparts journalists trying to get
afghan colleagues to safety local
leaders across this country standing up
to welcome refugees they know it's hard
they know we have to be in it for the
long haul they know it relies on give
not just take to build friendships and
alliances we can call on in times like
this a government that was honest with
itself
would see that alongside the united
states we have to have a broader set of
alliances so we can in operate an
independent foreign and security policy
again not to lecture eu companies
countries to show leadership over
refugees but to do this ourselves to
lead by example
with generosity and decency and step
forward when it matters not go missing
when things get tough
a self-confident country is one that
goes out with courage and conviction and
sheds light not just might around the
world that is the light that we showed
for two decades in afghanistan
in short mr speaker it is everything
that this government is not
so today he has a choice he could read
out those notes that he holds in front
of him or he could tear them up
and he could tell us the truth
how will we help them how will we repair
this how will we rise to the scale of
this challenge and show that we are a
serious country again prepared to engage
in the world and stand up for values
especially when it is hard he has hours
not days to make this right with so many
afghan people and repair our reputation
around the world we have so much to be
proud of as a country mr speaker can it
again include our government